Shadow Hill secretary is with this now
hello good morning you heard there the
nurse saying that potentially nurses are
looking at strike action because they
are burnt out they need more money they
can't go well do you know in more than
100 Years of their history the Royal
College of Nursing has never balloted
for strike action let alone taken strike
action what was striking about that clip
we just saw is it reflects what so many
nurses have told me over the summer uh
what the president of the Royal College
of nurses has told me which is that yes
of course nurses are worried about pay
and terms lots of people are with the
cost of living crisis but there's a
fundamental concern they have which is
working on understaffed shifts feeling
exhausted and burned out and worst of
all going home at the end of a long day
worried about whether or not they were
providing patience with the quality of
care they deserve suffering a moral
injury because of the Staffing crisis so
unless the health secretary grips that
Staffing crisis and sets out a plan to
recruit the doctors and nurses that we
need patients will continue to to wait
longer for care and I think after 12
years of this it's clear the longer the
conservatives are in power the longer
patients will wait but we've heard from
the Prime Minister and we'll hear from
the health secretary later on today that
the NHS is right at the top of their
inbox well if their policy is so good
why isn't the health secretary come on
your program this morning why is she in
hiding and avoiding media scrutiny I
think it's because she knows from what
I've seen trailed overnight but the
problems that or the solutions she's
presenting to the biggest crisis in the
history of the NHS are barely sticking
plasters they're not persuading NHS
leaders who've come out today and said
it won't be enough I don't think it's
going to persuade patients I mean can
you believe it after 12 years in
government they're saying great news
you'll get a GP appointment within a
fortnight I mean two weeks we guarantee
GP appointments within 48 Hours when we
were in government and asking the
conservatives now to fix the crisis in
the NHS it's a bit like expecting an
arsonist to put out the fire they've
caused these problems over the last
decade they don't have the answers and
and frankly unless they fix the
workforce challenge recruiting more
doctors more nurses we're not going to
get patients the care they need in a
timely way but Shadow house secretary we
have an aging population more people are
over 65 than under 16 more people need
to be seen by a GP we don't have enough
staff the um the government has said
they're looking to bring in 6 000 new
doctors before 2024 they're doing what
they can well they've admitted that they
aren't going to meet that Target they've
neglect to mention they've cut almost 5
000 GPS in the last decade and 330
practices have closed since the last
general election alone where I would
agree with your analysis K is you know
beyond the demographic pressures we've
got to look at the the long-term future
I'm clear about what that means it means
gripping the crisis recruiting the staff
that the NHS need now and also looking
longer term at the model of care well I
think in some cases particularly in
Social care the government's already
said they're going to invest in Social
care I think they should use some of
that investment to improve pay and
conditions for staff in Social care
because what we find is that care
workers are leaving the profession to go
and work for the likes of Amazon because
they pay better and they have better
terms and conditions and let's be honest
Amazon are hardly famous for their
workplace terms and conditions and
that's why we've got more than 400 000
people who are well enough to leave
hospitals stuck in hospital beds every
month that could be used by other people
for no other reason than social care
isn't there I wonder how you go if
you're in government how you would start
to pay for all of this I mean you're
talking about a windfall tax on oil and
gas companies doing it on the back of an
envelope
um it was it's going to cost something
like 29 billion pounds according
um to secure's emergency plan to stop
energy bills Rising
um over the winter
um this windfall tax would raise
something like 2 billion you'd have to
uh loan money wouldn't you know borrow
money no all of all of our policies are
being costed and every time we make an
announcement we explain where the money
would come from how we would pay for it
that's in stark contrast to Liz trust
who seems to now believe in magic Money
Trees who is resorting to borrowing
isn't being honest about how she would
pay for the things she wants to spend
money on and worst of all is pursuing
policies that may well be inflationary
so instead of gripping inflation
bringing inflation down which will be
the most effective way to deal with the
cost of living crisis growing the
economy so that the answer isn't always
to pull the lever on tax and to charge
working people more which has been the
Hallmark of the conservatives tax and
spending policies for uh you know recent
years and and sluggish growth for more
than a decade now we're very clear no
borrowing for day-to-day spending that's
there in our fiscal rules we've got a
big investment plan that would help get
the economy growing Rachel Reeves and
kirstan will say more about that our
conference next week but you know my
promise to your viewers is that when we
pledge to spend money on investing in
our public services for example will
explain where it comes from and most
importantly we're going to tax fairly
tax fairly and spend wisely that's a
stark contrast to the irresponsible
approach we now see from Liz truss's
government okay what set up the agenda
for your party conference which starts
this weekend well I think Britain needs
a fresh start we've had a conservative
government for more than a decade now
we've got to look at how we build a
fairer economy we've got to look at how
we grip crime and provide genuine Law
and Order which I think has just
spiraled out of control in so many
communities and of course in addition to
the cost of living crisis there's the
biggest crisis in our country which is
the crisis facing the NHS we're going to
have lots to say on those issues next
week and I think by the time that labor
conference concludes more people in the
country will conclude we've not only got
the right team in the labor party but
the right policies and values to meet
the challenges facing our country and
surely after 12 years of this government
and their abysmal record of failure it
really has changed let me ask you about
a fringe meeting that is about
abolishing the monarchy and I brought it
up on Twitter the other day and they
were very cross with me don't care
frankly
um
can you believe it
um do you think it's a good idea for
something like that to go ahead well let
me say as a staunch monarchist and a
believer in the monarchy uh I I I'm not
afraid of the debate actually
um two-thirds of our country last time I
checked support the monarchy can see the
benefits it brings to our country
um you know
admittedly against the extraordinarily
sad backdrop of the loss of the queen we
saw at that funeral last weekend
just the most remarkable display of what
it means to be British of pride In Our
Country Pride in our Queen pride in our
crown and the soft power that the role
family can exercise on in the interests
of our country now I think that's
preferable to having some elected
president I don't think an elected head
of state would have got anything like
the response or affection that the queen
generated during her long and
magnificent Reign but I'm not interested
in shutting down the debate I'm not
frightened of the debate I'm not
offended by the debate I'd happily have
that debate and I think the majority of
the country agree and I just
respectfully disagree with the minority
that don't agree